WADE IS HEATING UP THE SENATE
RACE IN NEVADA.
CNN'S SENIOR NATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT KYUNG LAH HAS THE
LATEST.
>> Reporter: IN THE BATTLEGROUND
STATE OF NEVADA, THE BATTLE OF
THE U.S. SENATE --
>> A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE IS
NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
>> MAY LIKE WITH SUPPORTERS LIKE
SUSAN RICHARDSON.
>> Reporter: HOW ANGRY ARE YOU
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENED ON THIS
ISSUE?
>> ON A SCALE OF 1 TO 10, ABOUT
A 9 1/2.
>> Reporter: THAT'S PRETTY
ANGRY.
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: ANGRY ENOUGH TO
REJECT HER PARTY'S SENATE
NOMINEE, AND INSTEAD SUPPORT A
DEMOCRAT.
IN 1990, NEVADA VOTERS CODIFIED
ABORTION ACCESS INTO THE STATE
CONSTITUTION, THEN A YOUNG
MOTHER OF TWO, FISHER WAS ONE OF
THE ACTIVISTS WHO WENT DOOR TO
DOOR TO CONVINCE VOTERS.
IN THE 202 MIDTERM ON THE HEELS
OF ROE VERSUS WADE BEING
OVERTURNED, FISH ARE FEARS THAT
WORK COULD BE UNSPUN.
>> I DO THINK THIS IS GOING TO
BE A PIVOTAL ISSUES FOR A LOT OF
RACES.
>>.
>> Reporter: HOW MANY WOMEN DO
YOU THINK ARE OUT THERE LIKE
YOU?
>> I THINK A LOT MORE THAN WE
KNOW.
>> THE POINT RUNNING AGAINST ME
WOULD BE THE VOTE TO SUPPORT A
FEDERAL ABORTION BAN.
>> Reporter: THE MAJORITY OF
NEVADAENS SUPPORT ABORTION
RIGHTS.
CATHERINE CORTEZ-MASTO IS
SEIZING ON THE ISSUE TO HAMMER
AWAY AT THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE.
>> I'M READY TO FIGHT FOR WHAT
IS RIGHT.
>> Reporter: HE'S BACKED BY
DONALD TRUMP.
>> THERE'S NO ONE MORE TRUST
WORTHY IN NEVADA THAN ADAM
LACKSALT.
>> Reporter: HE SAYS HE WILL
HONOR THE NEVADA CONSTITUTION,
BUT AN AUDIO SUGGESTS HE WANTS
TO REVERSE.
>> IT WAS ALWAYS A JOKE, TOTAL,
COMPLETE INVENTION.
WE HAVE WORK TO DO ON THAT.
>> WOMEN ARE OUTRAGED.
THIS IS A STATE THAT WE REALLY
RESPECT WOMEN'S FREEDOM AND THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE, JUST OUTRAGED
BY WHAT WE SEE HAPPENING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: THE OUTRAGE FRONT
AND CENTER IS ON PRICES
AFFECTING THEIR POCKETBOOKS.
>> GAS PRICES GROCERY PRICES,
HOUSING MARKET, ALL THAT.
>> Reporter: WHAT DO YOU WANT TO
TELL THE PARTY IN POWER?
>> YOU LET US DOWN.
>> Reporter: DEMOCRATS SAY
ABORTION RIGHTS ARE VITAL, SO IS
FEEDING THEIR FAMILIES.
>> OH, I'M KIND OF DEBATING ON
WHY.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
>> Reporter: YOU SO CATHERINE IS
ON THE BALLOT.
>> YES.
>> Reporter: WILL YOU BE VOTING
FOR HER?
>> MAYBE.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE.
I'M PLAYING IT ALL BY EAR RIGHT
NOW.
>> Reporter: SHE'S CROSSING THE
STATE.
MEANWHILE, IN JUST A FEW HOURS,
FORM